well this is somewhere in the middle of
the novel shortly after you know search
season his father have gone to a huge
fight when the fathers visited him in
New York and some months have gone by
and he's become essentially estranged
from his family and it's not until the
morning of 911 that he sort of realizes
that he should pick up the phone and
call them he's he's in New York in the
East Village and they're in Los Angeles
and so 911 becomes the occasion in which
he has to someone reconnect almost
exactly 8 months after his father left
him in New York xerxes Adam was awoken
to the hottest summer day of the year by
the invasion of a rather unwelcome
mental slideshow visions of that distant
prime creator his mother maybe he
dreamed of her all night every night
even who knew he hoped not he hoped it
was just his conscience and calculation
mode sending you the alarm that it was
time search seized time your mother is
waiting his mother had now left what he
estimated must be 100 and something
messages in 30 something weeks the first
third had been desperate and urgent and
worried please Xerxes she would say
adding my son in a shaky voice and made
him feels of his entrails were melting
the second third angry annoyed servic
trickling eventually to adjust pissed
snip eNOS and who are you mad at exactly
she would snap the third third cheery
oblivious delusional often delivered in
the form five minute plus long diary
entry like recordings that chronicled
her day just disjointed spewing zuv
whatever was on her mind at the moment
only at the end perhaps tagging on maybe
you will call or this is your mother
wondering how you are but none not
wondering too hard bye-bye or like the
last one here's to you being all okay or
whatever shab khosh it was the type of
goodnight you'd leave a stranger she
would slam the phone down and turn off
the lights at some point she decided
that calling at her bedtime would be
best they were three hours deeper into
the night and so he'd certainly be in at
one in the morning maybe to hell three
until midnight her time and she'd give
up and forced her
self to sleep but not without giving
would possibly pretend sleeping massive
husband next to a sharp nudge and
lecture this is getting crazy Darius she
would hiss into the darkness what the
hell did you do to him he's our son this
is something you did now you get him
back you hear me he's your son too I
don't care what you say just bring him
back to life he'd mumble incoherently
and toss and turn is it to signify some
grand struggle I'm telling you she would
continue some other parents would call
the police how do we know he isn't you
know Xerxes wondered how she would
possibly know if he was dead she
wouldn't this was one thing about New
York he realized immediately that to die
in the city was to die the end click
exit human no one would notice no one
would fight it or even interfere no one
would even notice no one was looking and
if someone found you will find you were
just another of the many who died in the
city daily mysterious natural unsolved
homicidal suicidal whatever you were a
number and if you didn't like that you
could leave he did not want to leave
there were sacrifices worth making for
the city he had decided long ago but it
did alarm him that perhaps she'd
resigned herself to thinking the worst
in this third stage of messages perhaps
she did assume he was dead and perhaps
she noticed any clues the contrary a
changed message greeting at best as
simple surprises grains of evidence for
an alternate universe she'd once fought
for but eventually tired of maybe his
mother had done with no other mother in
the history of the domestic matriarchy
had done in regard to her offspring
maybe she'd abandoned hope this barely
conscious reflection on his two years
two-thirds of a year's worth of
inhumanity combined with the sickly
stickiness that was peculiarly
oppressive 9am heat jolted him fully
awake as a from a falling dream of all
people why had he shed his mother from
his life he remembered being a child and
being mad at her her so much more often
than him because it was she who was
constantly stepping into his world
combing and gelling his hair when all
the boys wort messy wiping his face
fiddling with his shirt tying his shoes
for him always hollering annoying
reminders as he was on his way out
always checking on him at his friends
house is always
tucking him in with embarrassing often
at untrue admonitions or reminders you
were growing up you need to think about
smelling good now that you were growing
up showering regularly to begin with
because I'm about to vomit and I am your
mother or the most dreaded imagine
yourself in the future and think would
my silly behavior today get me there
what would a future wife think now once
in a while in a rage what would be gone
constant repeat loop in his head would
want to leak out and his head answered
everything everyone annoying an adult
was the sinister kitty staple I wish you
would die once to xerxes his own adult
embarrassment he remembered being pushed
pushed to say it out loud the best in a
week whisper what did she say she'd snap
furiously I wish you he had paused sure
he could see a glimmer of tears in her
eyes although in retrospect he thought
that any humans eyes naturally slimy and
liquidy could look tearful if guilt
steered you in that direction and he had
rephrased I wish you guys would die
psychologically it was better for him
but it's true genius wasn't being better
for her as well you guys became the
great equalizer it was something more
like I wish the whole institution of you
parenthood would die not you personally
all she had done with shake her head
she's still tucked him in and so he
wondered now too many years later how
it's six a.m. their time and their other
heat their dry dull warmth of West Coast
versus his merciless wet dirty big-city
tropical wave how he could reach her and
soften his blow he had basically in his
silence and his refusal to reach out
said to them I wish I was dead to you
and he had gotten what he wanted he
might as well be so when he finally did
it that morning did the dreaded dialing
of a number he grew up with was still
which still seems so natural with the
automatic sequencing of otherwise
illogical numbers that he had worked so
hard to render a natural he didn't even
consider that she might not be the one
to pick up as life goes it had to be him
his father with his usual gruff
reluctant hello that put the emphasis on
hell but she was probably conscious of
and probably found funny or else apt
there is no God Xerxes side
searcy slammed phone down shoving it
deep into a drawer as if to present
pretend it had never happened he closed
his eyes and buried the day back into
his pillow three weeks later a day after
the first one third of September 2001 he
finally called when life finally gave
him a push to put whatever pettiness
between him and that number aside if
only for a day when he knew risking him
could no longer be an issue that he had
to had to more than ever announced
himself as living as one of the many who
that day felt like a few who lived
through it so far at least and through
the few dial tones he said to himself
over and over there is a God there is a
God oh please let there be a god and
suddenly there she was answering without
even a Hello just that mystical
all-knowing mother's Xerxes and the
first thing he could think to say was
the only thing that he knew true in that
surreal hell of a day mother he declared
breathlessly I am alive Darius was of
course at her side just barely making
out the sound to the deceiver at his
wife's ear his son's voice was that
usually tinny hide chipman garble that
phones rendered voices it could be
anyone's voice he thought it all sounds
the same except that is my son his son
calling from the heart of a danger he
could not comprehend at the moment he
drowned him out and drowned out his
wife's over compensating awkward coos
and exclamations and turned the news
louder until they both disappeared into
the unrelenting dissonance of disaster
on the television they crumbled over and
over too tall perhaps too proud totems
of a city two towers erected to be each
other's image indistinguishable somber
doubles each dying the same death
neither intolerable when it came to
supposedly inevitable over and over it
replayed one went down the other stood
so low fast forward to a new clip the
other goes down just as a first and then
nothing where his son was it was sunny
it was also sunny where he was he
squinted out the window and imagine the
entire sky over America smiling
heartlessly he imagined in his homeland
it was almost dark he thought that there
was the best only a moon over Iran and
he thought how nice that was he closed
his eyes and gone were the repeating
images on the television and gone was
that blinding brightness and he
let the just so dark wall of his eyelid
melt into the image of the twilight
tehran sky it was time to go home